phil spector was prolific in the 1960s
producing hit after hit for stars like
tina turner
the ronettes and the righteous brothers
[Music]
he racked up 20 top 40 singles between
1961
and 65 and later worked with the beatles
on their final album
and then john lennon and george harrison
on solo projects
[Music]
his pioneering wall of sound technique
saw him layer several instruments
to give an orchestral feel to a song it
transformed
pop music you can't just say that phil
spector
was a great record producer which he was
or you just can't say he was a killer
which he was so let's ignore his
previous work
we have to be able to hold more than one
thought in our head at the same time
and phil spector was a great artist who
just became a wacko
and in the process of being a wacko
killed a woman
spector's life was blighted by
addictions to alcohol and drugs
and in the 1980s and 90s he became a
recluse
and hardly worked in music in 2003 he
was arrested for murder
after actress lana clarkson was found
shot dead at his californian mansion
spectre was convicted at a 2009 retrial
and jailed for 19 years he was 81 years
old
and would have been eligible for parole
in three years time
ended brady sky news